welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead season 11 episode 19. and
if you're a Walking Dead fan it's time
to get some awesome official merch from
The Walking Dead shop I've got one of
their supply drop boxes right here stay
tuned after the recap we'll see what's
inside we pick up right where we left
off in the aftermath of Sebastian
Milton's death at the founders day Riot
and it's obvious it was Eugene the sound
guy with his girlfriend Max her
assistant who would have been able to
record Sebastian who did this whole
thing and so our entire crew of Eugene's
friends are rounded up brought in for
questioning so Mercer interviews his
friend Rosita and his girlfriend
princess and they're both like Mercer
man why are you going along with this
the Miltons are the bad guys but he's
not ready for a full-on revolution yet
he's like look I'm just doing my job
trying to keep order but mostly he's
trying to protect his sister Max who
Pamela Milton knows was in on it he's
like sis you gotta save yourself sign
this confession blaming everything on
Eugene but she's like absolutely not she
gives him the same speech as the other
women in his life but he's still not
ready to hear it yet finally he and
princess have a real serious convo she's
dressed ready to go long story short she
tells her tragic backstory of her
abusive stepfather and it's like look
Mercer still serving Pamela Milton even
though he knows she's bad is related to
sticking with an abusive relationship
and Princess isn't having it she's like
I know you're a good man but I can't
stick around we're breaking up I'm out
of here now where is Eugene he's hiding
in the church with Daryl and they're
planning how to smuggle him out of here
but Eugene's not leaving not without Max
he wants to go out there and find her
even though he's the most wanted person
in the Commonwealth in fact he's
hilariously willing to fist fight Daryl
for it uh Daryl's like take your shot
man if you really want now the much
bigger crime that happened that day was
not playing the tape but you know
shooting the people and letting them
reanimate to zombies and Pamela Milton
instantly figured out that was Lance
Hornsby it seems his plan was to cause
some chaos so she would think she needs
him and set him free unfortunately it
backfired because he got her son killed
she's like hey let's let your lucky coin
decide whether I kill you now or set you
free to serve me and he picks correctly
yeah Lance Hornsby he's not dead yet but
she's got kind of a sick punishment in
mind because she brings in her zombie
Sebastian she also brings in the dead
body of Lance's assassin guy like hey
you're in charge of babysitting my
zombie son uh make sure he's fed yeah
people in the job apocalypse are crazy
meanwhile outside the Commonwealth we're
following Aaron who left with Jerry
Lydia and Elijah they're going to
Oceanside to drop off supplies then back
to Alexandria they stopped for the night
to have an old Renaissance Festival
where Jerry's like yo man this is where
we should have the kingdom Lydia and
Elijah have a blossoming romance but
she's not ready yet she still feels
guilty about Stick Boy Henry but Aaron
talks to her like hey this is the zombie
apocalypse you gotta go for it when you
got the chance but this is interrupted
when some zombies get in how's that
possible we checked the perimeter
multiple times so it's time for some
zombie killing Jerry goes into Samurai
mode they manage to get inside and shut
the door but wait to watch this the door
handles turning they figure there must
be some Whispers here so Aaron takes
this guy out like I hate Whisperers but
it's not a Whisperer it really is a
zombie are we doing the zombies getting
smarter thing they discuss it a bit
Aaron's like I've heard stories about
zombies that could open doors and climb
things and this is fun if you're a long
time walking dead fan you remember at
the very beginning of season one
Morgan's wife was trying to open their
door and a couple zombies did climb a
fence we just chalked it up too you know
they didn't settle on what the rules for
zombies were yet but now they're
bringing it up again seemingly setting
up zombies that our variants can do
special things back at the Commonwealth
Eugene decides that if Max is a prisoner
he's not leaving he's gonna do the best
thing he can and turn himself in he's
like hey Max had nothing to do with it
it was all me maybe they'll execute him
but he'll die a martyr but we're not
done quite yet because back at Rosita's
apartment oh she's jumped by some guys
oh they take her captive who said them
what's Happening Here find out next time
on The Walking Dead and now it's time to
check out some sweet Walking Dead merch
from The Walking Dead shop okay checking
it out all right well right on the top
we got a t-shirt oh snap it's freak of
Grimes that's right oh yeah this is
sweet it's not just the new season stuff
they got old stuff in here actually look
at this the other one is uh Dale's RV
got a luggage tag man I miss love those
days but we got stuff from new season
two it's Mercer the coolest character
from the new season oh my God it's a
little Mercer bobblehead I love it oh
and this is sweet little Walker pint
glass yeah check out that Walker now
you're drinking zombie apocalypse style
and maybe coolest of all we got the
canvas art collection featuring Maggie
yeah they got the whole series of these
there's one in each quarter Supply
Dropbox I got the Daryl one over there
behind me so yeah a lot of cool
exclusive The Walking Dead merch head
over to The Walking Dead shop right now
Link in the description and treat
yourself sign up for the supply Dropbox
they send you one every quarter you
don't know what's inside it's a fun
surprise but it's always sweet
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]